police forces around the world have made
hundreds of arrests as part of a major
sting
targeting organized crime networks
investigators say they gathered evidence
by tricking suspects into using a
messaging app
controlled by the fbi the criminals
thought their
cheats were their chats rather were
encrypted but police could read their
communications as they plotted drug
deals
arms deals and murders investigators say
the high-tech bust is an unprecedented
blow to crime gangs
not only have we heard about the number
rest and number of seizures
but there were over 100 threats to life
that were mitigated and to give you an
idea of the magnitude of
our penetration we were able to actually
see photographs of hundreds of tons of
cocaine
that were concealed in shipments of
fruit
we were able to see hundreds of kilos of
cocaine that were
concealed in canned goods
the success of operation trojan shield
is a result of tremendous innovation
dedication and unprecedented
international collaboration and the
results are staggering
the hundreds of the arrests were made in
australia and new zealand joining me now
from canberra is colin
packham he's a reuters journalist colin
how exactly was
it possible to uncover this network
hello so what we know is that for more
than a decade
organized criminals have been using
customized phones with encrypted
messaging apps
um those apps have changed over the time
but in 2018
the fbi manager can take control of an
app that became
wildly popular amongst organized
criminals um
so much so that the australian and
fbi were able to see 25 million messages
exchanged over the last three years
or by or vastly mostly by organized
criminals
well investigators did have access to
this network for years why the arrests
now
it's a good question we don't really
know the answer to that
um we know that the fbi will be holding
press conferences later perhaps we'll
get some details about that
but all we seem to know right now is the
number of arrests that's been made in
europe and in australia and elsewhere we
know there's 18 countries that have made
arrests but we don't know
why the authorities have decided to move
recently
we'll get to know a little bit more over
the next couple of hours i would imagine
uh colin tell us more about the type of
crimes that have been
prevented by these raids
yes all we know in australia is that
importation of drugs was widely used in
this app
but it weren't just limited to that
there were deals to buy
guns and also to plot murders so the
australian authorities believed there
were 21 plots to kill people
one incident involved a cafe and the use
of a machine gun and a cafe that was
thankfully prevented but we know that it
was a mass
use of criminal network that were using
this to discuss their criminal
activities
well it's probably likely that there are
many more of these criminal networks
that are as yet
undetected especially where you are
um well we know that there's lots of
encrypted apps
so we the authorities here think they
scratch the surface but
there is new legislation that would
allow them to view encrypted apps and
authorities are
very very keen to disrupt any activities
that they can get their hands on
colin pakken uh writer's journalist in
canberra thank you
thank you